good morning John I'm going to the
doctor's office gone to the doctor cuz I
can't move my neck I can't move my neck
I guess I can't move my head because the
head is the thing that your neck moves
and it hurts like in my arm and my
shoulder and I'm I'm worried about it so
I'm gonna go to the doctor he's gonna
give me pills so that I can get addicted
to painkillers like rush limbaugh and
Gregory House two of my favorite people
in the world cuz they it is so nice you
know it's kind of blows because we just
hit two hundred thousand subscribers and
I really I had a plan for a whole dance
that I would do that I can't do with my
neck like this maybe when I get home I
can figure out some kind of advance to
do something that doesn't involve a lot
of movement
this does make me think about injuries
though like childhood injuries all the
things that I've done to myself all the
scars on my body all the broken bones
that is a big freaking clock I guess
they want us to know exactly how much
time we're spending in the waiting rooms
oh maybe that should be our theme this
week John stories from our childhood I
could tell you the one about how I got
this guy want to hear that one so one
day you and I and a bunch of the
neighborhood kids were Brydon bikes
around Nick Jones's house I knock over a
potted plant in the pot brakes and so
all of us are like Oh something bad
happened let's run away so we ran away
and nobody fessed up to break in the pot
but then Nick's mom found out and Nick
totally ratted me out and so my mom as
punishment for not fessing up and for
breaking the pot made me do some chores
over at the Joneses house one of the
punishments was of course to take the
garbage out now Nick's mom did not make
me take out the bag of garbage that had
the pot pieces in it because they're
sharp and that would be a dangerous
thing for a fifth grader to do however
the bag with the broken pot pieces was
already on the curb when I put my bag
down and I went like this and you may
have guessed by now sticking out of one
of the bags that I had laid down my bag
on top of was a very sharp piece of
terracotta I don't remember the pain so
much I remember sort of a dull ache and
the warmth is falling down my arm of the
blood so I ran up in a panic to the
joneses front door and I knocked and
they let me in because I was bleeding
all down my arm this is my favorite part
of the story and really one of the only
things I remember about the experience
mr. Jones thought that he just needed to
wash some of the blood off to get a
better look at this
situation so mr. Jones stuck my hand
under the faucet you may want to mute
your speakers for this next part what I
remember was the skin of my hand opening
up and seeing the bones underneath
they call it an ambulance we kept
pressure on it and I was just fine I'm
home now so I'm going to do a dance a
kind of dance a dance that you can do
even if your neck hurts pretty bad let
me use ACCA's christina harness new band
all caps the song is called don't unplug
me
[Music]
I don't wanna know how long people have
been around so I'm gonna do this in the
comments below if you have been watching
since 2009 tell me if you've ever broken
a boat in what bone it was if you've
been watching since 2008 tell me about a
scar that you have on your body and
where the scar came from and have you
been watching since 2007 leave a comment
telling us if you've ever had a surgery
and if you did what for
I've had several surgeries I have my
wisdom teeth out I had this tendon
reattached and I had a hernia but I had
to get repaired i intestine to him
poking through my diaphragm it was
painful I just want to thank you John
and all the nerdfighters for helping to
grow this community and helping us do
all of the wonderful and awesome things
that we do and John I will see you on
Wednesday
[Music]